hi everyone i'm jonathan chance today i
got a particularly challenging tactical
puzzle for you so when you see it go
ahead pause your video and we'll see if
you can solve this really really tricky
puzzle so in this position it's white to
move so go ahead and take a few seconds
I'll give you five to ten seconds to
chill out listen to the music but this
is a very nice one so please pause your
video if you need more time okay so in
this position we understand that the
black King is in a little bit of danger
although black is up a piece so perhaps
the first move that we might think of is
the move rook to c7 and it's true that
this move does carry with it a small
little tactical point after King to f8
we can insert the move rook takes f7
however this trick should be
insufficient and it should lead to a
draw position after a few exchanges and
we take back the night on d3 so we get
the piece back but f4 is weak and
suddenly both Kings
might turn out to not have a whole lot
of safety and with best play this
position should be a draw so going back
instead of rook to c7 I'll go ahead and
pause your video if you still haven't
figured it out when it has a really nice
nice move in this position and the
surprising move is rook to c8 okay very
dramatic move but the more you look at
it the more you'll realize the black
simply doesn't have a good move in this
position so the first point is that if
you take the rook hopefully you see that
the checkmate it's just a maintenance
and the game would be over so it's
obvious that black can't take the rook
but what is White's threat the problem
really is that black simply can't move
he's almost in sub Swain in this
position for example if you play Queen
to d7
well then simply rook to c7 and white
wins material also you can't move your
King without you know if you play King
to f8 then you're hanging the rook on d8
and if you play a move such as Knight
takes f4 which looks sort of appealing
hopefully you can see the
here Queen f6 and after the king moves
over we take on d8 and we play rugby 1
and that would end the game so we go
back and another interesting thing in
this position is if black just plays
some sort of waiting move let's just
play h5 what is the the big deal what is
white really going to plan on doing and
the move rook to d1 is definitely a good
move but the most powerful and the most
beautiful move in this position is rook
to b8 the point of which is revealed
after say you just wait again
now we have Queen to f6 and you'd have
to go back to f8 dropping your rook
because now King to d7 hangs maton 1 and
you'll notice it's different in this
previous position we will understand why
we put the rook on b8 rather than leave
it where it is because if in this
position you play Queen to f6 check and
King to d7 you're no longer threatening
mate on d6 because the King could take
the rook on c8 so once again a very
powerful move in this position rook to
c8 truly artistic and beautiful move
thank you for watching everybody if you
did like this video go ahead and hit
like share subscribe Congrats to all of
those who are able to solve it and we'll
see you next week for another tactical
challenge